hundreds of refugees from bani shangul
in ethiopia have come to this camp near
the border with sudan for refuge
they fled fighting between ethnic groups
in the medical zone
amuna jumaa says she fled her home three
months ago with her four youngest
children
as they were all she could carry and not
a day goes by without her thinking of
those she left behind
they came and attacked us the civilians
they came to our village at night and
started killing us
people were running in all directions
parents and children separated from each
other
i fed with these ones into the bush the
others fell in the opposite direction
we were in the bush for 15 days as we
made our way to here
the camp has been set up as a temporary
center for refugees arriving in this
region
and is one of three in sudan's blunal
state that borders banishangul
benishan gulgomus is one of ethiopia's
nine regions and home to vast arable
lowlands and the grand ethiopian
renaissance dam
that's set to become africa's largest
hydroelectric dam
unlike most other regions in mexico the
gumus are the largest ethnic group
but the ones who fled here say they've
been marginalized in their own lands by
the amharas
who moved in from the neighboring
highland region that's led to fighting
at least 300 people have been killed in
the region in recent weeks according to
ethiopia's human rights commission
both sides have accused the other of
violence over the past few years
our problem is one of land the amharas
want to take our fertile lands because
they don't have such lands for farming
they found that our land is good so they
are targeting us gumu's farmers to
prevent us from farming
we don't want to give them our land so
they launch a tax on us because we are
weaker
since november authorities say more than
7 000 people have arrived in the state
despite being here for three months
refugees say very little aid has reached
them
they say most of the assistance they've
got so far are handouts from the local
community
and some refugees have opted to live
with the host communities
rather than in these makeshift camps
authorities also say that more people
are arriving every day
and that they expect that to continue
as long as fighting continues on the
other side more refugees will come
we're now racing against time because in
april it'll be the start of the rainy
season where the refugees are already
hard to reach
it'll be near impossible by that time so
we've identified a camp but it's not up
yet
we're hoping to set it up and move the
refugees in on time so they can get aid
easily
many refugees here say that regardless
of how few essentials are available in
this camp
they want to stay for as long as
possible and they're hoping family
members they've left behind will join
them
hiba morgan al-jazeera yeah baja on the
sudan ethiopia border